Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at mega lights and some
of the editing that we can do to control our shadows. So let's get started. So reminder,
for removing any shadow blotchiness that may occur or being able to finite make
your shadow sharp, you can go into the analytical lights such as the point light,
direct light and the spotlight. Particularly the point light and spotlight, you can adjust
the source radius. For the rack, you want to adjust the width and height, like we demonstrated.
For primary lights, such as the directional light, you want to adjust your source angle.
And that again will give you a sharper shadow versus a softer shadow. So for virtual shadow
maps, there are some variables that we can use to be able to adjust our shadow softness.
Also, there's the r dot shadow dot virtual dot SMRT, ray count local and r dot shadow dot
virtual SMRT dot ray count directional to adjust the number of rays. Now keep in mind the fewer
rays show visible noise in the parameter setting the associated console variable to
zero disables SMRT shadow map ray tracing and reverts to a single sample or hard shadows.
Whenever possible, you also want to make sure your geo is separated, built modularly,
and not all merged. Geo should also have volume. Try to avoid hollow pieces if possible,
to prevent any light leaking and blotchy shadow calculations. Now, keep in mind when
you do go to fab, you will get some pieces of geometry that are scanned, feel free to take
them into your DCC. And if you need to thicken them up, and get those new UVs and place them
and pack them accordingly. So that is possible to avoid that, if that is an issue. Now,
if you're facing not the hollow area, for the most part, you should be okay. But just keep
those things in mind. Now, like I said earlier, too, you can have weather geometry and lumen,
you just have to adjust those, those light cards in there, those mesh cards,
and that will make it so that you have cleaner reflections and not black geometry reflections
in your reflective surfaces. Then I meshes in the bottom here, you'll see if blotchy shadows
occur, you can try adjusting the fallback target and fallback relative error, as well as
position precision. All these are allow you to be able to edit things accordingly. If you
run into any trouble. So when it comes to big shadows, what you want to do, whether
using CP or GPU, you can override the lightmap resolution in the object details. This is
where I mostly do it, because I find that it's easier and is more consistent. In there
for the hero objects or objects of interest, you can make a higher resolution. And it
works out pretty darn good. To be able to see your GI builds accurately, you do want
eventually do a production bake. So if you're running your preview, when it comes to your
build quality, and you're noticing you're not getting the bounces, go and try it at
high or production, production being more ideal, because you're going to get your
final output there. So let's go ahead and talk about mega lights. We're going
to switch over into the scene that we had earlier, where it showed a beach and
a castle area. And we're going to talk a bit about that. In our scene here, I have
an active a mega light scene already ready to go for you. Now to be able to turn on
mega lights, there are several areas where you can do this. Let's go to our project
settings. This is our sweeping control, and will allow us to go in here and bring
up all the things that we need initially. So I can type in mega lights. And you'll
see that it is active. This is what you want to turn on initially to make sure things
are running, and that that will be calculated as needed. Now keep in mind, mega lights
is experimental. So I don't recommend them for shipping just yet. It's getting
there. And it will be there very soon. But just keep that in mind. Each light
that we have in place allows us to be able to actually edit it on a finite
level. So say I introduced a new light, we'll see that there's something, some
evil thing that's growing outside the beach, I don't know, couldn't come with
anything. And we'll make this kind of a red light just for that commit. And we'll
bump up its strength to make it pretty high. And we'll move it closer to
areas where you can actually see that influence. We'll go even higher, we'll
do like 500. There's a lot of fog and other elements in here. It won't make
it too movable, bumping up even more. There we go. And we'll place it higher
up on the environment, barely showing up here, get a little bit higher angle
for it. There you go. We'll see there's something creeping in the crack
here. Something very strange. You'll notice I have it up here, I could have
easily just picked the one on the opening that I will just pick it on
this guy here. So this particular light can even go even higher. This
particular light can also be mega lights also. And especially if I have
multiple ones. Now we have a scene where there's a lot of candles and so
forth. And we'll pick on that in just a second. But for now, we'll go
with the evil faced mountain. So in here, I can type in mega lights
also. And you'll see that it allows mega lights, I have finite
control. I can choose my shadow method if I want, we're gonna do
virtual shadow map. And you'll see these even if we want to cater or
edit things according to world partition. In this particular case, we
don't need to do any runtime grid association, because this one's
pretty simple. But for the most part that gives us full editing
control. Now in our post process volume, you also have
this option. So if I got our post process volume here, and
we'll go to the local beach, if we scroll down or something,
just type in mega lights, you'll see it here towards the
bottom under rendering features. And we can use flags if we need
to. So the user flag, accessible in materials via test
post processing volume, user flag. Now this can change is
allowing preview overrides of material behavior. So if you
run into any problems using mega lights, it trying to it
kind of it tries to give you that data ahead of time to
let you know, if hey, this is say you want a glowing
material that's giving off light, maybe it has a billboard,
which you saw in some of our demos, that those flags are
there to be able to help with association, and for you to
check for any errors. So in here, we have this setup. So we
can do it not only in the post process, but we can do it
within our project settings. And we can do it within our
actual light itself. Let's go jump back into the slides for
a moment. One of the things I want to point out is this is
used for all lights except the directional light and sky
light. So analytical lights only, it supports volumetric
fog. And mega lights not only reduces the cost of dynamic
shadowing, it also reduces the cost of unshadowed light
evaluation, making it possible to use expensive light sources,
such as textured area lights on consoles, and so
forth. Now you saw that in our demos in the past, where
you'll see like screens projecting light, and it does a
really great job of that. Mega lights can cause hidden though
these are some of the limitations cause hidden
shadows to disappear, only becoming visible with path
tracer. Mega lights is designed for current generation consoles,
PS five, Xbox series, and also limitations on support
strand based here. screen space traces used by mega
lights rely on scene depth, and will hit anything visible
on screen. This can cause issues with invisible shadow
casters that only exist in ray tracing in a ray tracing
scene, and don't affect the scene depth. So again, we dive
deeper into this inside of our atmospheric lighting course. So
again, editing, like we said, you can do project settings,
individual light, and in the post process volume. We do this
and give you this control. So well, you can feel drunk with
power. And you could edit things on a finite level or a
sweeping level. In the next video, we're going to look at
material optimization, and how that works when using Unreal.
Thanks again.